hello everyone my name is neo feminine
and I work for the JavaScript foundation
team for Facebook London and I'm gonna
be talking to you today about scaling
javascript build systems and more
specifically I'm gonna be talking about
Metro so the first thing I would like to
do is to show you a video about the what
the development process of react native
is for those who don't know what react
native is it is a framework built by
Facebook that allows you to use
JavaScript in order to create hybrid
mobile applications and it uses react as
well in order to represent the layout so
this is the typical development process
you change things into your editor we
have the iOS and the Android emulator
taking the change almost immediately you
can change text but you can also change
layouts you can change colors both
emulators will reflect your changes
almost immediately and the piece of
infrastructure that it's powering all of
these interactions is actually Metro so
to define it in a more formal way we can
say that Metro is the development
platform for react native and it does
that by exposing an HTTP server so
clients in that case emulators can
communicate with it and it also exposes
a WebSocket server so it can push
updates into the clients the main goal
is to build JavaScript but it can also
do many other stuff it deals with your
assets when you want to add a photo or a
video metric as well in charge of
bundling and adding this it provides hot
module reloading and to some extent is
also extensible because the main
interface we expose is a function that
matches with notes callback so you can
use that either on your note project or
on an express app and last but not least
it is also used in the divine building
process so once you've got your app
ready and you want to shape that to the
stores part of the building process that
will happen in your editor whether if
it's Xcode for iOS or Android studio for
Android the process of taking all the
JavaScript of your application and
putting that inside will be done by
Metro so
based on what we just explained it looks
like there are a lot of other
alternatives in the open source world
that pretty much fulfilled all of these
goals so why is Facebook building Metro
there are a couple of reasons for that
the first one is willing it to make it
fast and by fast I mean really fast
our scheme currently is at the 10th of
thousands of JavaScript modules and
we're aiming to be able to perform
reloads
on a sub-second basis so dealing with
such a large amount of code in so small
time requires you to have a specific
setup that we'll discuss a minute the
second thing is wanted to be scalable
you're probably aware that javascript is
kind of a trending language you can see
that based on the audience so the amount
of files that we have at Facebook just
keeps growing it has to work not only
for today's requirements for these tens
of thousands of JavaScript modules but
it also has to work for tomorrow and the
last and the third reason is we want it
to be integrated so Metra shapes when
you are developing with react native
Metro ships a set of really cool
features that are deeply integrated into
the bonding system and my preferred one
to explain this is the ability of
reloading your react native applications
by using the shortcut of command R or R
R for Android the way it works is Metro
brings up a global hotkey listener this
gets inside Metro and it pushes an
update towards the emulator so they know
they have to reload this for developers
that are used most to the web it gives
them a very seamless experience and in
order to achieve this you also need to
have very specific control on what your
bundler is doing and last the results a
little bit of history react native was a
project that was started five years ago
and back then there weren't that many
open source solutions so the first
iteration for Metro was something called
Jas app server we then turned out to be
the react native packager and about a
year and a half ago we extracted it into
its own repository which is what Metro
is today
ok so now that we know what Metro is
doing and where
we're building it I would like to get a
little bit into the technical details of
it and we're gonna do that by covering
all the different processes that are
involved in creating a bundle from the
point where you have your code up until
you get your app shipped into the App
Store's and executed by your customers
so the first part is about monitoring
the files on a project as we said we
have quite a large code base at Facebook
and dealing with such amount of files
can be slow imagine that every single
time you that you change the file you
need to reverse your whole dependency
graph if we're talking about big code
bases this can take quite a lot of time
so the way works inside Metro is by
using a module from a friend project
which is chest and in particular we do
suggest Hays map so just Hays map one of
the features it has is that it has the
ability of monitoring your file system
and emitting changes every time it
detects something on your file system
now in order to achieve this it uses
watchman whenever possible Watchmen is
another open source project from
Facebook which monitors your file system
but as a daemon process the cool thing
about doing so is that if Metro gets
killed and then you restarted you don't
have to recrawl the whole file system
again you can just query Watchmen and
tell watchman hey can you give me the
changes that happen since the last time
I was alive which dramatically reduces
the startup time however on pretty much
like all open source projects and
general development people does not have
watch my installed so if we don't detect
watchman on the file system we just fall
back to the fest but watch this has a
startup cost overhead but after that
they're pretty much the same so now that
we know all the files that are gonna get
into our project the next thing that we
have to do is transform them and in that
aspect met for the with any other single
bound or two which is we use babel the
thing that it's a bit different in Metro
compared to other bundling systems is
the way we execute Metro so
transpiration is a very expensive
and it can take a lot of time so most
funders will have their main process and
they will execute the translation
process one file after the other you
take a transpile a when you're finished
you take B and so on and so forth if you
have once again a very large code base
this can take actually minutes to happen
so metro uses a different approach
instead the main process doesn't
transform any file but it spawn a set of
child processes that we call workers
files are then sent in parallel to each
of these workers the translation happens
at the same time and then we return the
results back now we spawn approximately
one worker per core which means a time
reduction of six to seven acts on a
Macbook with eight cores so this can cut
down building times from minutes to
seconds which is pretty good now
paralyzing the process of translation
poses a new set of problems
imagine that worker number one is
dealing with a very complex file and it
turns out that you change again 8oj s
well the naive approach would be taking
a and sending it to the first available
or available worker which turns out to
be worker number two now part of the
translation process they tend to have
caches intermediate caches to make
further translations faster if you
remember from the previous slide a was
transformed by working number one so we
said the cash on worker number one if
you now send a DOJ's to work a number
two you're gonna end up with the same
cash on work number two and this is
pretty bad both in terms of space and
time it is bad in terms of space because
memory between workers is not shared so
you're going to duplicate the same data
structure and it is about in terms of
time because since you didn't have any
cash you will have to retrain file from
scratch instead what metro does is it
implements a queue for every single
worker so the first time you transfer a
file it will be sent to the first
available worker but once it gets
returned the file will get stick to the
that transformed it now if you want to
read transform it we will put it into
the queue in that case of work of worker
number one and we will wait for the file
to finish in order to send a in to the
right worker the overall process right
now here is an oversimplification
because it looks like working number two
and working number three on our idling
and we could just have taken that one in
real life what happens is that worker
number two and worker number three
they're also busy with their own set of
files so it is not that we just have one
worker super busy and the rest idling
but the load is actually distributed
across all of them now the model that
powers this once again borrows from
another project is just worker it has a
very simple API to create these kind of
forms of workers we have an example on
the repository about paralyzing left
path which is not very interesting from
the practical point of view but it shows
how how easy you can do things cool so
we've transformed our files and with the
parallelization it becomes pretty fast
but we still want to be faster than this
and in order to achieve this metro ships
with an internal cache this cache is a
multi-layer cache and it is located
inside the main process now the way
works is you go into the first cache
layer if the result is there you will
return it and if not you will go into
the second cache layer and you will
repeat the process through all your
layers every time you want to transform
something inside Metro you will go
through a function called transform and
this transform will call into the
caching layers now the first one that we
have is a local cache this cache leaves
inside your laptop on the TMP folder and
it's used both in open source and
internally at Facebook now it could be
that the thing that you're looking for
is not on that cache because for
instance you just checked out a new
version of the code and you don't you've
never seen that faster it was never
transpired so for that we have a second
cache layer which is a centralized
database that one is only available at
Facebook but the code is open source so
you could in theory use it that as well
and this centralized stash is accessed
by all developers now we go into the
cache and we look for the file could be
that the file is not there as well
because it has a local change that used
to give just on in that case the only
thing that we can do is go into Jess
worker and transpile the file once the
file is transpiled we put that into the
local cache but we don't write to the
global cache and the reason for that is
that if we save every change that every
developer is doing through the day we're
gonna end up bloating the cache and
there is no benefit for that because no
other person will make the same
modification over the same file and in
approximately the same commit instead at
Facebook the centralized cache is
fulfilled by a continuous integration
job that runs on master and every time
we see a new file which is transpile the
file or a modified file which transpile
the file and restore it now in order to
store something you need a cache key and
a value the cache key is built by Metro
by combining two parts we take your
source file and we hash it but we also
take every single part that is involved
into the process of transpiling the file
and we also have it and the result the
cache key we use is the union of both
the cool thing about this is that
whether if you change the file itself or
you change the way you transpire you
don't have to worry about invalidating
the cache so if you didn't have the
second part and you change the way you
transform either you had to invalidate
the whole cache which can suck for
people that it's not yet onto that
commit or you would be serving stale
results for some times which is not good
either so that was for the key for the
value the value is the result of the
translation process so if we take this
module for instance and we transpile it
it would end up looking something like
this
so Const got converted into var it got
wrapped into the function and we've got
the defined call etc now inside Metro we
do not use string identifiers for
modules instead we use numeric
identifier
other bundling systems like web pack and
browser if I can do that through a
plug-in but in the case of metro this is
built inside the core of it the reason
is for performance reasons it's always
faster to do a lookup through a number
and for size reasons a number is always
a smaller than a string now if you catch
this you're gonna have some issues
because these numbers are local to your
build so while this could work for your
local cache for the centralized cache
when someone else is going to pick that
module they their build with crash
because left pad could be a complete
different model than the number 42 so
Metro does not really hard code numbers
it adds one level of indirection by
using an array of numbers and each of
the modules is change each of the
reference of the modules is changed into
a position into this array now side to
the module we also store that position
number zero is left path and position
number one is five and when you build we
make a lookup into the table we extract
which is your local number for these
modules and we add this array to the
Defiant call okay so we've got all the
files transpile and we're ready to
produce a bundle metro produces bundles
sorry through something that we call
serializers where you receive the graph
and you can manipulate it in any way you
want now there are two default
serializers shipped with Metro the first
one is a plain JavaScript bundle and
this is when you're developing in react
native in open-source it's the one
they're you more slightly using this is
it produces the same format that any
other bundling system will just take all
the modules one after the other we
concatenate them and at the end we add a
startup code the startup code is 99% of
times require 0 because we assign
numbers in DFS look like when we
traverse the graph and your entry point
will almost always be the first module
now there is a second format which is
called random access module bundles and
this is not a text file but a binary but
a binary file
this file is composed by three sections
the first one is a magic number this
magic number will help us identify when
we try loading it that we're not loading
a text file so plain JavaScript bundle
but Ram bundle it stands for fb0 bundles
or something like that
now after that we've got a table of
contents the table of contents has the
amount of modules that are shipped into
this big blob the startup length
remember the startup code was this
require zero and references to where
each of the module is located into this
gigantic blob and after that we just
write the code starting with the startup
section and each of the modules and we
put after them a new character and I
have to plain you in a second why we do
that now the amount of modules let us
know how big the table of content is the
startup length is how big the initial
length is and each of the offsets are
pointing to the first byte where the
module is located within the file so the
format might look a little bit
cumbersome but thanks to the table of
content we can access any module in
constant time
with very simple maps we can get where
it is located and this is especially
relevant to execute code on devices this
is very specific to react native as well
and is a little bit tricky so I'm gonna
explain you first how we execute how we
require modules that were previously
required and then we'll take a look at
how we load a module for the first time
so when the module was previously
required you will have into memory your
require implementation and all the files
all the modules that were previously
loaded now when you want to require
something you will call in to the
require implementation and the require
implementation has its own internal
cache for instance because requiring
twice the same module has to return the
same instance it will query the cache
and then since the module is there it
will just return it now this is a pretty
straightforward process and again
literally every single bundling system
does the same now when you require
something that was never required the
process get a little bit trickier we
have a once again require and the
modules that were previously loaded
and our required call to something that
we've never seen the process starts in
the same way we go incidence in to
require we make a lookup into the cache
and then 622 in this case is not there
so we got a load it and this happens
with a little trick for loading 622 in
the case of react native we do not use
JavaScript we use the native side the
native side has a function called native
require which require will call and will
tell hey can you please load 622 inside
the JavaScript virtual machine now
native require will go into the disk
look at this guy antic blob do the maths
take the first bite of 622 will extract
where it is located and will inject it
inside the virtual machine now this is
the reason why there is a null byte at
the end of every single module because
all implementations of JavaScript
virtual machines are C++ based or at
least they use ASCII zet strings by
putting a new character at the end of
each module we don't have to worry
neither about the length of it nor
copying it into a separate buffer we can
directly tell the virtual machine to
just load the JavaScript from there now
once the module is loaded inside the
virtual machine it will self register
inside the require implementation and it
will appear into the cache and the only
thing that it's left is release the
native require and now require will be
able to return that module this process
pretty much like the ramp format looks a
little bit cumbersome but it has some
benefits you have to pay off every
single time that you cross from the
JavaScript side into the native side but
on the other side you're only loading
the minimum amount of JavaScript that
you need and you're not consuming as
much memory as you would consume
otherwise loading a plain JavaScript
bundle will still be possible but it
will take a lot of time and a lot of
memory and not all devices are capable
to handle this so by doing this you're
only putting inside the code that you
inside the virtual machine the code that
you really need to execute
so we've talked a lot about how we
bundle coal you know how we execute code
you know a lot of the building process
but what happens with developers because
we said that we were looking for
sub-second reloads for our developers so
how have we made this work internally a
couple of months ago approximately four
months ago we develop something that is
called a delta bundler and this is also
open source and it is part of the metro
so in order to figure that out how it
works let's take this graph as an
example where your entry point is module
number one and the arrows means the
first one is requiring the second one so
module number one requires the second
one and the sixth one number two
requires three and four and so on and so
forth the first time you want to load
this inside the device we will take all
the files put them all together and send
that to the device now if you change
model number six but most wonders do is
they will retry verse from number one
get all the dependencies create a new
entire bundle and ship that into the
client but the truth is out of the six
module only number six changed so what
the Delta bugger does is it creates a
Delta just with that module and sends
that into the client now the difference
is massive
because instead of having an O and
operation every time you reload you've
converted the operation in an o1 it
doesn't really matter how big your
codebase is once it is loaded for the
first time on the device you don't have
to worry about sending everything over
and over through the network the process
works like this for most of the changes
there are slights modifications when you
add or remove a require so when you add
a require we have to extract that
require and start crawling again from
that require and through the through the
crawling process we only extract the
modules that is the first time we visit
so for instance module number one
required number seven and number seven
requires four eight and nine to work
however we know that four was early
loaded into the virtual machine so your
resulting dev will only contain module
one seven eight and nine
in similar fashion one when we remove a
require we have
to verify that this was the last require
going to the file in that case model
number three stops requiring module
number five but module number four still
depends on it what it means is that the
Delta that we can send is only module
number three now if we also change
module number four and we remove the
require five becomes an orphan module so
we can safely delete it and the
resulting Delta for this is patching
module number four but also deleting
module number five so to summarize this
most code changes only require patching
a single file so we've gone through
having to create a giantic bundled with
megabytes and megabytes of JavaScript
into sending just a few kilobytes now
when you add a require we just trigger
that search through all the new requires
that we might visit and we take only the
ones that is the first time we see on
the other side removing a require does
the inverse operation so instead of
depending on direct dependencies we
depend on what we call inverse
dependencies so we look at who's
depending on a module in order to know
if we can safely delete it or not if no
one's depending on the module you can
safely delete it now as a quick recap we
can say that Metro is a building
platform where the scaling issues are
put on every single part of the process
so we made transformations in parallel
we have multi cache systems in order to
avoid having to read transpile files
that someone else transpile before and
then we have the code execution in the
most optimal way both in development and
in production so if you want to try
Metro if you're developing a react
native application you're already trying
it you don't have to do anything all the
features have described our part except
for the global cache because we cannot
shape the global public has all the
features I've described are in there
with and we're also working into making
it for a suitable for other platforms so
there are really cool examples about
this this is a video of
react native application working on a
browser
the thing that is powering this I would
totally recommend you to check the video
this is just five seconds this is also
powered by Metro and in fact we're
currently working in making Metro
suitable as well for web and for that we
have a very simple application that a
colleague of my team made so you can
just go and download it everything works
on that app except for the Delta bundler
we are still figuring out how we're
gonna implement this on the web might be
service workers but this is definitely
not there yet
but in any case is actually powered by
Metro and that was all for today thank
you very much